[Music]
hey everybody welcome to episode 20 of
the 13 o'clock podcast our first episode
of 2017 I hope everybody had a good New
Year and to kind of celebrate our first
episode of the new year we actually have
a guest on this one which as you'll know
is quite rare and what a guest it is
he's an awesome guy's name is Steve Mara
and he's a pair of psychologists that
we've known for a few years and I've
written a couple books with him and we
interviewed him for about an hour about
parapsychology about some various
investigations he's been on and how he
got started in the field and stuff like
that and it's really interesting so I
hope you guys enjoy listening to it as
much as we enjoyed doing it and here it
is okay here we go and we have a special
yes today on 13 o'clock on our 20th
episode first of 2017 yep good friend of
ours and a partner yes that's right and
it is per psychologist Steve Merrill
Steve is a field pair of psychologist
can you tell us about field
parapsychology Steve yeah he's just a
word but one minute details is the
workings of paranormal research and
psychological research altogether which
is reverses power knowable psychological
phenomena some people work from
universities a lot of our psychologists
in the UK establishments at
establishments and I adore research
programs to me I'm Bob field pop
psychologist amount in the field
analyzing in investigating events as
they happen unfold
hopefully for me to bring enough
evidence back to provide the
establishments with enough data to
consider paranormal phenomena taking
place so it's kind of split you know
psychologists possibly
we know which are you could say about
activating the fuel and those which are
researchers from the scholarship okay so
an activist as the guy who's out there
actually he's investigating a researcher
he's reading other people's books that's
basically what the research side what we
tend to have is continued despereaux's
target experiments which is pique Sacko
Commissioner psycho psycho Jennings crab
initiative texts also given things which
might take place over research programs
at universities a lot of means there
she's gone from yes people are
considered doing working people before
and documented them and findings of all
the people research that we do for
meetings more hands-on it's about being
there experiencing phenomenon examining
and is it real isn't it real for
millions for sort of gap in the pilgrim
do it as opposed from reading yeah
when did you start parapsychology what
did you get involved in it and well I've
started off in engineering actually many
years ago was an electrical engineer a
large security engineering went to
telecommunications but then I worked
contract work for NATO in the UK Essex
for a short time before I still do
sociology a little bit of counseling and
then I'll take my psychology pre degree
and then degree at monster University
we're talking probably about twenty
years ago now and I went on to do it was
buying car psychology courses there even
be very different depending on when you
get them from
I need a couple from the US of his some
overseas sort of the UK and they were
basically very you know regarding the
data new promotional provided when I
wanted a general scope of what people
considered what was passed on ecology
what are the power normal attributes to
like research and
generally feel where everybody was
coming from because of what I realized
very quickly is that to be honest not
many people really know exactly what it
is since I don't wear the same place and
they is why my psychology simply exists
and bots when he comes down to the
fundamentals how does it work
why is it happening there is still very
real question marks regarding that so
when did you actually start to
investigate this stuff at the paranormal
that was back in 1983 April of 1983 was
my first investigation Liverpool in the
UK and but as time went on throughout
the late 80s and into the early nineties
I couldn't help notice the psychic
ramifications of many UFO experiences
where these four times our paranormal
attributes so I kind of let me into the
paranormal increment that was not to
consider how a normal for know whether
we lose some of those experiences for
instance you know people report the
alien abduction phenomena example people
after before piranha fish join those
experiences they've no different than
the providers which is reported during
paranormal shows so there's these all
the terms wearing on these crossovers
these connections between two phenomena
and I wanted to study more in the field
of paranormal and of course once I
opened that door then that's really the
complexities of the paranormal
outweighed ecological phenomena ten to
one and of course I headed you to the
paranormal research and started
investigating the first paranormal case
that was learned about the late 1980s
when I started getting there a number of
interesting cases which I looked into
and then I kind of stumbled into
confidential corporate investigations of
paranormal phenomena Wow now do you do
this just like a freelance type
situation or do you
you have to like join the SPR actually
how this works when we have our little
organizations use SCP the scientific
establishment our psychology which is
probably more dealing with the power
normal as opposed to another
organization which devotees map it
achieve Manchester's anomalous phenomena
investigation team or he's got probably
different equities much like in people
it just depends I mean we initially were
aerial phenomena investigation team then
he became anomalous phenomena because
once let people know we must gain all
sort and now it's Manchester's
association of have a normal
investigation training because we deal
with a lot of training as well someone
we wanted to keep the map in equity will
just change the wording sliding to let
people though what we actually deal with
so it's kind of caught down the middle
depends on what cases come in is should
they go to warm up here or should they
go to assessing people in the paranormal
in base investigation but fundamentally
what happened was I got a phone call
many years ago for Manchester's public
relations office and asked me if I would
assist them in the gastral disturbances
which were taking place at the building
now that time we would even tell me what
the building was it was very it was more
like I was being assessed or interview
in a sentence a sense of speaking assess
for this investigation and that was
quite I was quiet thinking well what's
his book insist on it's all very very
strange and it turned out that I would
being vetted and he could got the flu
investigation on behalf the Ministry of
Defense UK governmental bodies and
business or consulate properties and you
were both housed in the same building
which was owned by the Ministry of
Defense at the time which was known as
so my house and they actually had could
not a corker and confidential
investigation which I did so Google
today investigation along with 36 or the
investigators now because it was such
confidential the whole case we had
suppose as electrical engineers
we were suited all with equipment in
hard hats and all sorts of these so you
can well imagine as you know our
investigators are going about doing
could not judge surveys and test at the
building when they're the staffing that
were actually engineers a normal
investigation we also talked with six
members of staff which had experienced
paranormal phenomena some of them were
there almighty there was one lady she
was she was crying you should know that
she was scared of to work in the
building the problematic stop soldiers
there is that it became a management
issue which they didn't know how to deal
with because staff wouldn't work late
hours and wouldn't work in certain parts
of the building now so that's
problematic for any business and it went
on filter management and of course they
didn't really know how to deal with it
so it's awfully probably relations
officer this is why we have adult
getting involved now when we talk to
this one of those member of staff she'd
Hannah normally birds in Indy female
toilets of the building where and she
was in there on a revenant she convinced
somebody come in and it was clearly a
man and the heavy brooded and she was
served she was actually sat Robert
silent of all things when they're that
male the man's boots
popped onto the cubicle door man cause
he's highly raised off the ground and
she could see even deep roots called
there was what she could understand what
is that the boots were so far forward
that the chest and stomach area of the
intestine would have had to have been
coming through the doorway Wow from door
but he wasn't she won't talk just
expected to see a person well Norman
Shaw you saw was the back of the door
he's bruised clearly underneath the door
popping into the cubicle so much with
the movie as well and she absolutely
freaked out so some kind of ghost this
was some kind of ghost case there well
it certainly was yeah
we reach and security which we're
dealing with the business and they have
a 24-hour surveillance and it's what we
refer to as a 24-hour handover so what
happens is the couple of magic guys the
security guys if they don't experience
anything they make notes and then they
hand them over to the morning guys and
they treat series throughout the day and
this cycle went on for quite some time
then we were provided with over 300
sheets of information pertaining to the
paranormal disturbances other witnessing
including and giving chase to who they
thought was intruders when in fact they
were the issues who were intruders at
the time only to give chase and see them
literally walk through a wall or a
locked door and immediately look the
conclusion we were giving chase the
apparitions those disturbances went on
for quite some time
and Wendy members of staff is reported
things and the security officers and
some of the CCTV footage and also people
involved we could alter their quite a
wonderfully investigation we didn't
manage to assist them certainly because
of the electromagnetic energies of the
geomagnetic energy naturally emanating
emanating from beneath the building
because the building has these four
giant concrete
rods are divided into the ground for
stability but underneath the building is
the old canal system and the electrical
systems you can which we could see was
all attributing to high EMF and
geomagnetic energy and of course when
they came in and move things around
including equipment electronic equipment
these hot spots or spikes areas were
prominent where people were reported
paranormal disturbances on a regular
basis
so whatever happened with that case was
that ever a result we carried on about
six months we did manage to get them to
recur store parts of the building to
eliminate that very peaks and troughs of
EMF of GMO and we also have certain
staff go through processes and
counseling how to deal with paranormal
incidents some of them were relocated on
the part of the building it was quite a
lengthy investigation but we did make it
a manageable situation the staff and
that's what the main thing was was
causing issues for the staff working our
location we ended up finishing the
investigation at the mouth seven months
and they were quite happy - very happy
with the wind that we carried out now
that was my very first corporate
confidential investigation now something
unusual happened from that because this
case just came out the balloon with a
phone call for lunches with public
relations after bill my investigation
saw how my contact details ended up on
sonsaku Network Information Agency I'm
not too sure but I was a gentleman I
would seem to be the guy to turn to in
regards corporate confidential
investigations for businesses companies
and things like that and lots of cases
will come in from all over the country
for me to look at in this confidential
professional manner where the people
were you having me with my clients and I
was I was there to do serving is
paranormal phenomena taking place and if
there isn't is to manage the situation
in a in a professional manner so nice
not detrimental to the business or if
the MIS paranormal phenomena taking
place and also to be able to try and
manage that deal with it regarding
making sure that the environments are
better for staff and the whole situation
a whole bundle melded problem as his
other was is that cases came in from
supermarket chains
football grounds will be growls hotels
shops stores businesses companies ten
Tennis Association's house an
association City Council and they ever
got doing 17 years solid work for
confidential businesses and that sort of
thing
seventeen years I think that I still do
get coffee classifications come in I
don't take so many of them now obviously
because it's time
well it's time there were hundreds there
were hundreds of cases and and they were
very high-profile some of these cases as
well so we have to be highly
confidential about some of the the
things we were working with we were
through police appointees seeing ID
units the million CID also we were
within regarding the suing case I've
reopened because of information I was
allegedly obtained from a summer psychic
in regarding a murder which information
was given which hadn't been documented
empirically well so it wasn't known by
the general public yet this information
was obtained and called cell and giving
to the police another not to over the
investigation of causing to assess what
the situation was so we have dealt with
a lot of different types of cases on a
corporate side of things but we do still
do residential investigations we don't
what we don't do is we don't go to
escape their homes and haunted pumps
probably you take all of them we get
involved in cases where he needs our
systems the most frequent of cases
reported sewers are you usually
hauntings not the amount of what what we
have to take on very low we're very very
choosy about the investigations RSVP
undertake normally there has to be an
agency on strawberries involved all
these numerous winters lots of witnesses
on quite a number of evidence all it's
basically very prominent in the media my
my
one of those five scenarios and we don't
just tend you know we just don't go
running to people's houses for daily
call something that go bump in the night
a lot of analysis takes place a lot of
psychoanalysis in some cases where we
talk with the witnesses to do serving
doesn't even want any investigation
because many people go out there he's
kind of caught down the middle you've
got a lot of Gary's out there in groups
and organizations which kind of just
want to go out film something photos
capture something and that people check
they'll go away but they're happening or
it's about the principle thing you do
with a witness to make you slaughter
them okay how to better their lives and
that's the main thing can we assist them
because some of these people are having
traumatic experiences and we don't know
who to turn to
so we have worked with with those type
of incidents those people and course
we're closely with churches and all the
religious establishments over the last
eight years so so it's safe to say that
yeah okay it's safe to say that you've
investigated hundreds of cases over the
years hundreds of them probably nearly
yeah out of all those cases what
percentage of them actually had
paranormal stuff going on in would you
say well that's dependent on what we
found out first when in certain cases of
even quantity was we fall in a chain we
follow how the information bottles I
mean in some cases people have been
having distances for over a year and
then you know I'm continent finally got
to all starting to talk so I would say
lower our office and we work out and
obviously there was simply over as well
gives you opportunity for people to
rationalize things quite a lot so you
just really depends on how the case is
come about how long has been going on
for
generally speaking only about I've said
about eight to nine percent of them ten
percent that most our our
misidentifications
I'll be wrongly thoughts on defending
452b power when it isn't most of the
time the people are contact ESCP I've
already done the footwork
I've already pretty much done all the
basics and pretty much worked out
concluded yet this looking left in this
has to be seen in parallel and then the
end of winter was so usually a lot of
always already be done even though that
we have to still go over the old ground
and so yeah we don't tend to get we do
get the other one cases where I guess
there's a partial explanation and most
of the power normal distance is because
these reached a certain level by the
time the contacting law is that that's
already being done it's already been
pretty much established by others that
power level phenomena so sauce is taking
place what we all know that okay so by
the time it gets to you yeah okay now in
case the audience doesn't know jenny has
written two books about cases that
you've been involved in the Rochdale
poltergeist and the house of fire and
whispers case which is the key blender
yes the demons in Seattle case you know
how the term demons is because I didn't
fall in line with the name that
reference came from a television program
and which weapons that episode even Zeus
yeah now I really I quickly realized
absolutely was not demons you know even
though I have been involved in what you
might occur
more a whole more supernatural time
phenomena a commission count them on one
hand
over 30 on years so they are extremely
rare those cases
so to just play out with that that was
diamond in Seattle was very misleading
but what we were dealing with us as it
states in the book when we're dealing
with a policy guys investigation but
also haunted as well which share which
you can remove the rule book a little
bit are I mean I'm not the only person
to ever come across use these incidents
where Lee seems to be a bet about both
sides pon cigars and haunting type
phenomena but it's never been recognized
officially and we've always been thought
to do micro subjects when in fact I
think was probably best for any
investigators just to say that it is
reporting as it is because sometimes
terminology and these subject rackets
that we make can be accurate and I think
sometimes though there are a combination
of phenomena taking place in cases and
we wrongly force them into these wrong
brackets so for all be calling an
intuitive haunting whistling podcast
investigations have stopped going on
there it was an extreme case no what's
the difference between a ghost and a
poltergeist or a Harding and a
poltergeist
can you explain that to us yeah well
whole teams tends to be long-lived
intensely go on few days especially like
places like in the UK when we refer to a
haunted building that still sounds it
could be a hundred five hundred thousand
a thousand years old you know I mean
whole tooth could go on for a long long
long time and it kind of been offers
they may because the poltergeist
infestations they tend to be short-lived
they tend to their cumulative the
resourceful so what they do is they
carry on building and building and
building upon phenomena should've each
the peak value once it reaches a peak
value then it seems to disperse now is
what happens how long it takes for that
peak value to to rise to 82 days to the
top part the week before dissipation
and that can sometimes be several months
ago sometimes just be ova
also as far doesn't tend to last for
very long
but what is interesting is that they are
the most productive the most destructive
even probably the most intelligent of
all paranormal disturbances that take
place is simply different because of the
guys phenomena can be dismissed written
in can act or on the on the solution of
days where it tends to be volunteers
tend to be a bit more you know elusive
instruments take place at night and the
following people Swede it could be quite
the opposite but one thing is for sure
is that a new form of the same heavy
with paranormal as to what they are is
lots of speculation hauntings are often
referred to is the haunting of a spirit
spirit that was once alive as the
multi-vise these different variations if
releases regarding what they really
consist on one word on zone their lives
is that they are are the other entities
are an intelligent entity that is never
been human or a fallen angel I mean dude
gem tree in time encountered also
community really but it does seem to be
a quite a clear divide between the type
of phenomena that's reported between
quality and sometimes mistaken
Wow you started talking about ghosts and
poltergeists and we're getting the
weirdest sounds coming over your
microphone
again that's so weird and now it's
fading away yeah it kind of sounded like
a motorcycle engine or like a yeah or
like a hard drive kind of running or a
truck or something like yeah it's weird
did you hear anything on your end Steve
[Music]
what time is it is it how are we doing
on time should we take a break um we can
or we can do a break at the end if you
want to do a break now we can let me do
a break now okay because we're almost
we're at the halfway mark okay we'll let
that sound resolve itself okay okay all
right so I'm going to we'll just give me
you know okay so we'll be back in just a
minute
it was a time when we raced to the TV
Guide to see what was playing on monster
movie matinee that Saturday afternoon
and in some cities that evening it was
all about werewolves vampires giant
lizards and those great Japanese monster
movies relive it all every week as Jim
Adams and Mark Maddux bring you monster
attack monster attack takes a look at
those classic monster movies that we all
grew up loving join us every week on
monster attack exclusively on the
project Entertainment Network if you're
into cosplay corsa trees steampunk
gothic or rockabilly clothing shoes and
accessories then you must visit
subculture corsets and clothing either
online at www.haddadtoyota.com your
entire purchase or when checking out on
their website use the discount code 13
o'clock and receive a 10% discount on
your entire order and if you're a
full-figured girl don't worry subculture
carries sizes four through 4x and they
have men's clothing as well that's
subculture corsets calm and use discount
code 13 o'clock for a 10% discount go
check out the
website now subculture corsets calm or
when traveling through Jacksonville
Florida stop in and check out their
store at the avenues mall project
Entertainment Network presents Buttercup
of doom with your host Kelly Owen just a
girl a girl who writes horror and
thriller fiction talks to bugs jumps and
puddles and now hosts a weekly podcast
full of opinions advice and a touch of
gypsy wisdom whether it's current
affairs or social media nightmares join
me as I rant and rave and offer up a big
old bucket a common sense Wednesdays I'm
Buttercup of doom
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone there's a brand new podcast
starting on December 1st the Dead TV
podcast where we take shows from the
horror industry that had been cancelled
or ended and review them episode by
episode starting with kindred the
embraced and Constantine you'll have to
stick around to see what the third show
that we're doing immediately after those
joining me for this amazing new podcast
is mr. zenica hello everyone thanks for
having me
mr. Seneca is an event hostess of kinky
geeky and sexy parties around the
Philadelphia area she has a flair for
the dramatic and is passionate about
zombies she also teaches on a wide
variety of BDSM topics including high
protocol in fact you can say she wrote
the book on it which you can find at her
L website wwlp.com thanks so much I'm
happy to be here chris is a longtime
horror fan and turn that love of horror
into an almost decade-long radio show
called radio of horror he wrote a
children's Halloween book in 2012 called
give me something good to eat it has a
comic book forthcoming or he gender
swaps the entire counts of Dracula
looking forward to that on the side he
also makes sure horror films in
Massachusetts so how could I say no and
you can get all the updates about our
podcast on our Facebook page the dead to
you TV podcast and eventually a
forthcoming Twitter page as well so stay
tuned for the first episode coming
December 1st
there's harrows real and imaginary and I
write about them all paranormal go to
WWJD AFRICOM or search Amazon for the
Jenny Ashford author page okay we just
cover difference between ghosts and
poltergeists what would be a little bit
about Rochdale okay's because I wrote a
book with Steve Mara about the Rochdale
poltergeist case which happened in 1996
and there was actually some pretty
amazing stuff that you guys saw when you
were on site so talk a little bit about
that well you know when I first went
online investigation of a genius we have
been called in by los Del City Council
there are claims they said that the
family would report it amongst
outrageous things and they couldn't work
out exactly the reasons why they were
recording here and they had been some
damage to furniture in the house and all
sort of different things alone that we
were to go in there and assess is there
any truth to their claims the council
said to me remember again the council
things we love Islam no not in the UK
they're sure that sometimes just
sometimes tenants will make up a story
about the power novel because they wants
to be rehoused into another location and
use that as an excuse because they can
always argue the point well things don't
happen with you all there yeah also it
can generate bad press so sometimes it
can force the council's home so happen
relocated that was brought up in
conversation with me from the Bastile
City Council however I quickly learned
when I got to the house and talked with
a moment that they didn't want to do
they've been there 14 years they were
happy
in fact that she you know quite saddened
at the fact that they having to have to
move they didn't want to do that
whatsoever
Bobby we're faced with something that
said they did what needed resolving
because you couldn't live under the
conditions they were out there the most
notable thing was the water damage
remember going into the house of the
babe first family we nostrils were
filled with that horrible damn smell
like me death or water damage and
quickly looked around and saw plastic
sheeting on the floor and furniture also
all over the place and they claimed that
they've been water damage too because
water for means water that was suddenly
apparel doors walls and ceilings and
even on occasion in rain inside the
house now count the councillor being
several terms and door for investigation
and they couldn't find out where the
water was coming from I mean the lovely
yes that's okay little leaky pipes or
there's ahead of time full of water all
down I wasn't a lot there is no had to
turn to the lots of bursting in real
life secondly there's no pipes up there
either
they all coming from underground is a
prefabricated bungalow with a hard floor
and were initially built as temporary
homes during the Second World War but we
can it became permanent residence and
the garden coming like that say 14 years
in what a move we were very happy there
and so these incidents started happening
about temples prior
now the because the council couldn't
find any rational explanation they only
could assume that the family was before
he warned her about themselves and so it
was for me to do so many battles I was
for taking place or not but I quickly
realized after talk in interviewing the
family there was a lot more than just
for me that was being reported there
were audible disturbances there were
things being moved around
were damaged items things absolutely
disappear and never be found again at
variables poltergeist infestation and
for me I had to look into the criteria
does it fit the bill for those people
are investigated or no considerable
amount about politics infestations they
tend to target certain families
sometimes these children adolescent or
female than male in some cases and you
usually is some type of upheaval it
would probably be being that these
funding issues or financial problems or
even just general upset that seems to be
very prominent in this case and they fit
the criteria for from Ponce Castle
investigations immediately so I was
aware of that straight away we was also
interesting that we got confirmation
from a priest I had attended the house
and witness phenomena himself in fact it
was a very large painting that flew off
the wall and hit him on the leg and that
was taken back really because this is a
Catholic priest and they're usually a
little bit more
well they don't tend to blurt things out
my social phenomena they're a little bit
more reserved when it comes to social
subjects however within two or three
minutes of meeting the crease and I mean
for me I was investigating the Gardner
house incidents on behalf of but of
osteology council he immediately said
it's a poltergeist and that took me but
because I didn't expect him to be so
forward about that but say it was under
them well he had contacted the diocese
in regarding
assisting the public but was informed
and what we do so I understand that it
will be pointless for him to conduct a
blessing or an exorcism who some people
which is less
who is a blessing in my pocket if you
try to disperse it for no one because it
was a poltergeist investigation and
rarely do they are they positive to that
type of things taking place like
blessings and things also ask for our
tents be more like haunted people as
opposed to a haunted building so it was
he was informed I probably would not be
advantageous to conduct a blessing
because it being considered to be a
plastic ice infestation of the haunting
so we kind of took it from there but
there was a multitude of incredible
phenomena the likes of I've never seen
ever never seen it since never seen it
out doors open or prior and to see in
water for me would suddenly appear on
the ceiling intelligently move our legs
like fittings on the ceiling creeping
across the soon as it has some
intelligence and at the same time not
dripping to the floor well there wasn't
a rare variety of different type of
water phenomena suddenly beads of water
appeared on a door completely covered
which just came out of thin air and I'm
a building agent mr. Gardner was sat in
his kitchen with an umbrella wall and it
was heavily raining in the kitchen and
it was fascinating to to know that I did
see at least three or four o'clock once
the wards and meet a large pool of water
that would manifested in the kitchen on
the ceiling and them quickly antics as
the appearing he would disappear leaving
an immense amount of water damage around
the property and that continued for
quite some time amongst all the
poltergeist type experiences we ended up
having to relocate and in the end we did
confirm with a sit down visa with
washed-out City Council that yes they
were coming also guys do stones was
taking place there the family room where
we located eventually and the house was
left fallow for quite some time I mean
follow housing left
a void of complete electricity that to
hopefully disperse dampen the phenomena
to the point way doesn't it doesn't even
sound dissipates a new family moved in
there when special survey was taking was
take was to take place
ask them a number of questions which
would lead us to believe if those having
any continued phenomena in that in that
location they were which was good
so families will live happy and normal
lives which is we just go through all
because the foremost thing is taking
care of those experiences those
witnesses now one of the things I really
like about this case is then it reminds
me a lot of the Donnie Decker case also
known as the Rain Man case and you know
that was also another culprit guys that
involved man water and there are a lot
of good witnesses to it prison staff the
police sought and no and and in that one
well let me ask you this do you believe
poultrygeist or at least this family of
poltergeist phenomena do you believe it
to be our spk or do you believe to be
spirits of the dead or a combination of
both okay it can happen but just because
it can happen doesn't necessarily mean
always is now what was interesting about
the boss Dallas is the logical council
case this is poltergeist infestation is
by ruling straight away that phenomena
always follows the individuals they
really individuals phenomena so that we
did that we got the whole bundle into
two days and we invested into that
building getting continue to have
infestation which makes it very
interesting because then we're dealing
with yes a posthumous infestation but
not necessarily directly our socialable
so those in the environment so we did
come up with storm oh and yes there is
and possibly is the derivative at the
beginning to start the folklore the
catalyst but my scarf is pros
but then I think once he starts building
developing between colleges over mention
so that you can remove the family from
that location I'm still happy to
phenomena class depending on how much
momentum the reason that has they had
been a lot joined this particular
investigation so immediately we realized
straight away it can be anybody who'd
seen anything because there's nobody
there to do it you know so that was done
that was a steeper loss because we were
witnessing phenomenon firsthand in a
location where well it's a very good
case in the book is very popular now
that was an older case that we we all
did together but recently we've all been
involved in the production of a book
about a more controversial case known as
the demons in Seattle case yeah now this
started off with one of the ghost hunter
programs found this one found this case
before you got involved in it what do
you think of these ghost hunting
[Music]
generated a lot of interest in the
subjects at the Parliament want to show
the downside is that it's usually it's
not true usually Penn State there's only
a very very very very far away from what
I would investigation I'm sure there's a
lot of guys out there that run
organizations and groups themselves and
then will tell you exactly the same
thing is that you know always watch you
program a little raised diagram because
at the end of the day you know you
cannot by rule of thumb walking
someplace and all hell great they can a
TV show and then I've got a lot of TV
show little over 100 television it will
go well and I know from from doing it
when we go into a location we want to
build
then we mark anything well sometimes we
have to film on a location for a week in
the hope of possibly getting something
but then there's still no guarantees so
I've always jeebies about cases you know
these guys going into places a little
help making straight away doesn't always
tend to work but it also brings forward
it's an opportunity and a benchmark
these programs to bring forward the
latest gadget technology in ghost
busting in ghost hunting now I've always
said this to people it's isn't the
equipment it's the hounds eating that's
all because there's one thing
fundamentally I believe about what we
all own the law and that means at the
end of the day it's down to the
galleries the spirits if you want to
call it but I don't like to name them I
don't like to pepper the ball you know
whatever they are intelligent responses
you told you interactive phenomena if
they are spirits then we have to rely
upon them to choose to interact to
choose to do so
there's not believe for one second that
they they are not going to line up in
their droves to talk to those opposed to
team I don't think that the case may be
in fact those at the time I think
they're probably elusive I think
phenomena think a lot of things we can
drive there we can we can pull it off
because you know we've got all these
different sides of equipment now the
downside is is that they
cross-contamination is huge between
equipment
I mean I've talked to people 20 years in
the field what didn't know with the
rampart going off you know that oh we're
getting responses they've been going on
about this for a long long time truth of
the matter is is reacting to the
walkie-talkies that were in conversation
in the next room and that been going on
for months and months if not years and
they didn't even know it is really
important to check cross-contamination
between equipment and use of utilizing
equipment for the light of thing I mean
we watch a lot of TV shows where people
walking walking walking about leyline
EMF meters left or right in there in the
air
the meaning that means up is best used
when static you know we fix it on a
particular location where you've got
normal background radiation which should
be between nor point-wise not whether
two Miller girls and then be there and
then then you start getting a spike in
activity in the location where you
didn't have anything that means that
something must be punch wars with you
guys and that is when it's worthy of
Investigation we live in a technological
world does these EMF of GMO a
geomagnetic everywhere from mobile
phones to to radios to shortwave or
thought everywhere it's impossible not
to walk in certain locations to the
fields are where we're all and captured
things on equipment that we might be
normal when in fact they have a much
more mundane explanation right okay so
the demons in Seattle case
Keith lender tell us a story how you got
involved in that case an incumbent for
news coming out from the states and a
lot of contacts in the states and those
cost over to recently one day he no off
at when said Steve have you seen this
and yeah this was a bit dodgy you know I
lost be too good to believe these babies
emit sensationalism here my friends get
involved
[Music]
and then how caffeine Belgian Bacon's
their way I'm not an email from the
actual guy Keith Linda regarding the
disturbances Icehouse Holy Ghost
Adventures regular normal TV show got in
there and done an episode you tackled
season ten called demons in Seattle and
I thought it was interesting that's
interesting why would a TV show like
that with every single episode of
generating alleged phenomena suddenly
have nothing in one episode all the way
so I treat me but then you know this is
a counter-argument to that there is a
counter-argument that couldn't be simply
because viewers while she getting two
seasons had interest in the TV show with
rearing got people thinking that they
were less credible and understandable I
can pretty much go reviving some of the
store scene on those opportunities you
maybe want to check in jets water for
the reef that they are completely
midgets and that's about all their
actions joining making such TV shows we
don't the saying that we didn't find any
evidence so as well so really what the
hell was going on it wasn't a case for
me I talk to people and I express my
concerns about you know pretty much
stage you know doesn't look credible so
much medium interests this case we
should normally be shying away from it
well it was because of his is constant
asking first systems because he said
he's tried everything then he said that
he tried to concert he concerts at the
TV show he showed you that scene
television episode in home he was hoping
to gain assistance fatik make things
worse for him of his power and he wanted
some metal Lucian to this fellow and
what was happening why was it happening
and what are people coming at least we
do a thorny investigation to say hey and
say as it is so savings and long
conversations to a place with this
decayed Linda and only airing of months
we were psychoanalyzing with questions
sheets of marking sheath with which
which are given point priority systems
to award points for sincerity probable
or fourth important citizen we were
looking for those four we were looking
for everything that might lead us to
believe something cookies they were gone
after doing that the most we could only
conclude that one or two things that mr.
Keatley there was in fact delusional and
actually did believe was phenomena or
someone was living
with key on a regular basis which was
production trickery and making Keith
believe that though our normal things
taking place what is for sure he was
absolutely adamant you know we don't
quite sure that he would be true for
sincere which sparked our interest so
under certain conditions and we didn't
tell Keith that should we be involved in
this investigation we will say as it is
team are you really sure you want our
involvement because we comply with
founders of miles of the other side of
the planet to call you investigating
your home and then we find hope in going
on we will publicize it we will push it
out every single place that we possibly
can to the point where you won't be able
to do schools fish without anything
you've got a thinking that you don't
even privy to obviously faking things so
you know he was completely aware of our
action and he said that's exactly what
that's that's great I have completely
agree with that that's that's good under
those circumstances so we decided to
take on board the preliminary
investigation which persisted on just
six days and because of the amount of
phenomena was taking place we have to
return for a further eight days
investigatory evaluation and it was
remarkable absolutely but I've never
done an investigation like that before
and I agree with Bobby quite prolific
cases and now that one was certainly
something significantly different
because from stepping foot into that
house to lead it I want him I just could
not fathom is that how can a ghost
haunting TV show going there for six
hours and not witness anything well it
was always a probability
6,000 obviously fell at the other day
however we were there for two weeks I
will show you you know the I came up
with their sleep exhaustion and that is
simply because of one reason lies
because when I was taking place
so maybe love it I didn't want to go to
sleep
yeah whatever what exactly did you see
see well it stayed over the first things
that I experienced with audible
phenomena things being banned and moved
around and that sort of thing then there
was the sound of somebody walking around
I actually gave change to one that I was
quite funny because it seemed to react
to being chasing me and run off so it
was kind of a cat Mouse situation and it
was that was really quite comical
actually you know when you look back at
set balls it was seen that whatever it
was were they're highly interactive
highly intelligent to the point where
they were trying to assess the equipment
that we were using and it was only
because we changed the process on my
investigation after 48 hours Olaf
started the investigation of the house
our results seemed to multiply because
of the process of investigation was
greatly changed we mainly don't do
something with well I mean this isn't
this is the problems of these type of
cases other people have been involved
all the other organizations and groups
of donning tikkis panels going in there
and they have said to keep we caught
this we've got that we photographed this
popular now we were presented with a
mass of information now the downside to
that is that we we have to only judge
make know on what we did whilst we were
there over that period of time we can't
completely say for sure anything cry or
anything pensive
you know because it's always going to be
maybe something man going there and
probably something that's at all the
exactly that he might not but you know
we do we are aware of that so that was a
really that was a really problematic
thing for was joined by investigation
but there was a lot of different things
reported there was a lot of different
things that's variances
damn it was phenomena came straight out
of the air on three occasions
one of which actually stopped our
conversation
yeah actually interrupted our
conversation with Luke just incredible
and we also had already both phenomena
being recorded on an honest Kalin just
unprecedented as far as I'm aware I mean
I can't we came out visit one for the
first six days we came by with 256
gigabytes of information and 427
captured audio phenomena
how are those volumes 20 70 was about
sweating on which would Class A actual
voice phenomena three data points
pedometers and most of them consisting
of EVP Class B can we only have about
families plus C's which we would have
just completely thrown out anyway
but doing phenomenal new additionally we
like to believe might have been
something Native Americans and that they
may have been yes happen occasionally
and in that location
and because of that some people believe
that paranormal phenomena can manifest
but we didn't find enough evidence to
support i'm not simple make sense all
the same defining what we did find own
credit labels lots and lots of Irish
accents which we transfer in our heads
thinking why what about how we've got
Irish all these Irish accents in college
even in conversation even between
themselves on our equipment in in a
place in Seattle and of course it's only
further research on you know that
provided by information where we
discovered afterwards that love Irish
have been brought over for violence at
work in locations of C apples have
felled trees and make way for building
projects and of course loss of them will
killed buying Indians because they was
Native American around there that I mean
I've got lots of skirmishes and battles
of walls to a place and lots of Irish
people did die just as is a lot of
Indians and so is it a location where
possibility while mayonnaise Irish
accent but we didn't know that other
time no one so we had to go back waiting
on information that we filed for
regarding research there was we went
through the musician kind of a libel
well because it will now not be able to
reason while be getting that chance
here's one of the really cool things
when you guys were writing a book
together Jenny actually she had access
to all the video from this case and the
e-book is interactive well yeah the
e-book if you if you get the e-book of
house of fire whispers what I did was I
just kind of you know in the text where
there's a link to you know a particular
photograph that I'm talking about or
whatever like you can just click right
on it on your e-reader and it'll go
right to it and there are also some of
the better EVPs that turned up on that
case which are really kind of creepy
it's not it's not a case of like
sometimes you see on the ghost shows
where it's like writing a book about
case there's no evidence for just
pulling it out of the air no we we
actually have the the EVPs and the video
data yeah
so this movie the different it's it's a
great book bulb in case it hasn't sucked
still it's even evolving now with will a
prominent and how would a half
documentary being constructed about it
are the official report is also due out
about the end of February of this year
and when I say involving it is because
even the electronic voice phenomena or
the actual voice phenomena we've
suddenly is after specialist the best
best people we know and the responses
back on the road going pop one quote
what the hell was that you know things
like that because these guys are
specialists a nice for hearing evening
and think about my manger
that wasn't saying I have no idea what
conversation was I have no idea what you
recorded it does not follow the normal
consciousness of EVP it does not follow
that the passage of frequency the sound
generated from it are definitely voices
but don't follow the normal normal vocal
pattern we're finding thousands of all
these are the little bits which are just
building building building because the
narcissist does take time you know
research does take that we're still
waiting on further information but you
know we're digging and digging and
digging to try and find out as much as
we possibly can from from what are the
objects that flew off the wall and all
standing when nobody was up there came
crashing to the floor lights now no way
not my shouldn't come off that wall it's
hot Tom you have to lift the light off
we need to come up away from the wall
now the recorders were running though
the record of measurable measures in a
decibels from that sound when hit the
floor we went up there we tried to
replicate it
when we replicated the sound is exactly
the same but nowhere name is loud it was
seen that the sound was amplified sort
of Wathan it for the paranormal action
in other words maybe to gain our
attention but there is a distinctive
difference between the actual account
happening on the reconstruction and the
actual paranormal incident even though
that we considered to be one of the same
the sound was certainly not so we are
finding all these wonderful little
things the probably the most significant
of all data ever our table a parallel
investigation was what we obtained there
was the phenomena of trance placement
where we see that we have multiple
different recording devices all
simultaneously learning at the same time
in sonic environment of recording
different things a female and male ones
and something else all the same thing on
different recording mediums that means
it's about harmonic that means that
they're being down that being placed on
two equal pieces of equipment and he
turns placement
and we did come across DBP that was
phenomenal three occasion that we'll
also consider that can transplant be of
a psychological or physiological
condition yeah we were heading to
research into you know people with
cochlear devices in fact goblin
problematics with their ears and hearing
since birth empanadas and these cochlear
implants is replacing to the brain
allows them to hear things bypass
individual now if Derek voice phenomena
can happen you to be hearing how would
how sure are we by it's actually
harmonic and it's luckily variables
oh is it translates tools just as they
are these pieces of equipment
so that's a must-pass are pathological
breakthrough and just in the field
empowered old mechanics there which is
confirm this one investigation so we
really is leading the way and there's a
lot more to come about this
investigation to come over the years I'm
sure is we're going to be finding out
more more more from the analysis that we
from the all the data that we collected
over to me period
so you're also involved with phenomena
magazine right yes we have there which
is a monthly magazine it comes out in
the UK at the end of every ball it's
free to down the bone of phenomena
magazine UK the magazine covers pretty
much everything really all sorts of
things from things going for tonight but
people seem strange lines and also so he
sort of those photos magazine three
aspects of anomalous phenomena and it's
free to download every month we're going
to issue probably about eight eighty and
ninety now why is good that all back
issues are free to download on the
website as well last phenomena magazine
okay okay so what you working on now
Steve you got to you working on any new
cases or case is always ongoing we're
still working with with analysts at this
moment in time we actually are going
over to meet them in Ireland
within the next few months so that
should be interesting
and we are also got a number of
Investigations to do in a location
called Staffordshire in the UK three
investigations in regarding a mystery
actually it's never been never been
solved regarding a possible serial
killer so we are it's surprising what we
get involved in but so where is some
power or phenomena associated to the
buildings and parently associated to the
incidents of some place their economies
so we are going to be getting into that
a little bit more over the next couple
of months but we've got a lot of things
in the pipeline we're currently doing
this documentary and that should be
ready by the end of February we had a
huge amount of interest from the u.s. in
regarding the house of fireball speech
documentary and it basically it's going
to show you clearly so it's not going to
be one of those shows of all the bells
and whistles like a ghost school student
goes with the TV show it is a
science-based program it is about true
power normal phenomena and the
statistical analysis of Scientology's
and he'll tell you what to do with it
and even once we show you firsthand the
evidence that we captured from a shadow
apparition that was a phantom leak or to
audible phenomenon in fact it's costing
I don't know what we do these guys are
discussing amongst themselves as to our
women we use it it's absolutely
ridiculous I've never seen anything like
it in my life opponent will never ever
come across something like that again
bull he's called going to be included in
the documentary for people to see and
hear fantastic Steve anything you'd like
to plug Jenny before we wrap up
probably firing whispers yeah yeah we
just want to tell the listeners that um
Steve and I wrote two books together
about two of his cases house of fire
whispers which is about the Keith lender
case and also the Rochdale poltergeist
yeah well my gardener family in 1996
that was the water poltergeist the what
yeah that we were
discussing earlier and what yeah I think
we're running out of time yeah we can
wrap it up okay Steve bill thanks for
coming on we're gonna have you back on
soon maybe maybe quarterly huh yeah no
guys only plenty to cover always go yeah
well see you later guys thank you very
much and there you go I hope you guys
liked that interview and we hope to have
Steve Mara back on on a semi-regular
basis because you know we are good
friends with him and he is a really cool
guy and he has a lot of projects going
on and you probably need to check those
out phenomena project and various
documentaries and stuff like that and
also if you liked our show of course you
can always subscribe you can like us on
Facebook you can like us on Twitter
where we're at 13 o'clock podcast and
also if you go to wwl calm slash 13
o'clock we have 5 different t-shirts
there if you want to check those out and
also project Entertainment Network on
which our audio version of our podcast
is hosted have a patreon page so go to
patreon and search for project
Entertainment Network and if you could
throw them a couple bucks that would be
cool supports us of course supports the
whole network and supports all the other
cool podcasts that are on there so I
hope you liked the show and be sure to
tune in next Tuesday bye
you